now this is quite a unique episode right
here because for the first time ever
I've tried and do a livestream but at
the same time record I never did that
before especially on my laptop because
it just couldn't handle it
but I decided to try that on my PC and I
think it actually turned out very nice
and there were actually some moments
where I left the game but thanks to the
fraps
it doesn't actually quit rollercoaster
tycoon 3 at that point so we don't have
weird windows in the screen and
everything should be fine and even
though the stream was a bit messy the
time-lapse did come out great and I
think other people have been doing this
and I like the idea because of course it
means that you can time-lapse and make
videos at the same time and it's more
fun and it's more efficient and yay
we're all happy and what I wasn't happy
about though was this building obviously
since I'm removing it and it's gonna
it's not gonna be gone I just didn't
like the position over here I figured
that I wanted to have well one I wanted
to have a kind of Bulevar over here and
while I'm talking I kind of just
realized that I've got a terrible reverb
in my room sorry I'm sorry about that
but the problem is that my room is kind
of empty right now and that's why I have
this weird echo here but anyway I wanted
to have a Boulevard kind of thing over
there with like loads of arches and
pillars and classical buildings because
you know I know I love those things so
why not go for that and speaking of this
building I am NOT removing this building
because I dislike it per se I just
didn't like the place where I was
standing I was just kind of standing
there and blocking the beautiful view of
the rest of the city and I couldn't see
[ __ ] really trying to look at the
skyline from over there
and that was his massive MOC in the way
which was this building and it was just
blocking the view so I decided that just
for the sake of aesthetics of actually
the skyline looking good over the mass
that it had I wanted to move this
building and actually place it over here
which is where I was originally going to
place other skyscrapers but I decided to
just place this thing here and that's
something that I do want to talk about
because win it I don't know if it's a
good idea to give tips about that
because I don't see too many people
building cities in Monaco second three
which is quite a shame if you ask me but
you know
you can't force people to do that but I
do like it because it lets you have a
lot of freedom and more so than the
cities like Sim City for example which I
do like to play as well but oh my god
what I wanted to say was that you've got
primarily two types of skylines you've
got the skylines where it's one massive
block of City nur's which is which has
loads of skyscrapers which are all
almost identical and height and shape
it's just one big box of boxes which is
kind of like New York where the skyline
is very massive and impressive as a
whole but the buildings on their own
don't really stand to much ground and
that was a terrible saying to use oh I'm
sorry about that
and then there's also the skylines that
are much smaller in size as well as in
amount of skyscrapers that they have for
example Frankfurt or a Singapore where
the focus is much more on the individual
buildings and the way that they look in
the skyline and if I'm going to be very
honest I actually do like the second
skyline more it almost feels like I was
bashing New York though which I don't I
love it and the thing that you do need
to remember in both sizes whatever
you're going for is that a skyline
always needs a distinct signature Tower
for example New York has the Empire
State Building and on the other side of
the island of course it has the Freedom
Tower which I don't know this is a good
idea to talk about it's quite well it's
quite a controversy but I wanted to talk
about this because sometimes I see
people complaining about the Freedom
Tower which of course they're why
wouldn't they be able to do that but I
actually do like the idea and the tower
as well
I mean 9/11 is quite a well controversy
to actually talk about but I I do like
the Freedom Tower for the fact that I
see many people that actually dislike it
because either they want Twin Towers
back to which I would say well you got
seven towers back and I actually do
really like the design of the Freedom
Tower because it still has that box
shape going on that their World Trade
Center Twin Towers had but I also think
that
if you were really going to rebuild
after such a terrible thing
you probably shouldn't rebuild the exact
same thing that was there but I do like
the idea of actually doing something new
and even more groundbreaking than you
did before because that's how you will
truly make a comeback is what I'd say so
I do like that Tower
it's actually my favorite skyscraper in
the world I actually do like it more
than the Empire State Building I know
it's got a very simple shape but that's
exactly why I like it and one more thing
and this was actually the point that I
wanted to talk about is the fact that it
has a very high spire of course it is
incredibly high and the thing that it
does it's a signature tower for there
not just a reason that it looks good but
also that it's much higher than the
towers around it and it almost creates
like this mountain is shape where you
have this one big tower in the middle
and smaller towers around it and all the
way down to the outskirts of town there
buildings just keep getting smaller and
that's an idea that I like in the
skyline and that's why it almost feels
like a stereotypical and perfect utopian
skyline to me so that's why I like that
if you look at it many skylines in the
world have that I mean Hong Kong has one
has the commercial center which is a lot
higher than the rest of the buildings
and well practically everything has that
except Rotterdam because everybody over
here likes what to them for some reason
well I know some people don't I actually
had my teacher say that well yeah the
bombings of the Germans were pretty
terrible but well we got a very nice
city back but I actually don't like the
Rotterdam skyline a lot for that it's my
favorite skyline in the world and what
what am i said okay hold on it's my
favorite skyline in the Netherlands but
it's still not that amazing because it
what it needs is a signature Tower
it's called amazing towers all around
the city but what it really needs is one
tower that's much bigger than the rest
and actually lifted the skyline to be
much more beautiful and that's something
that I need to do with Silver City as
well because as much as it's fun to
build this little Boulevard with arches
and pillars and all that New York
classical stuff that I've done so many
times before but it still looks so good
and oh yes is
the fact that you need one big skyline
thing in the middle which is going to be
that glassy spire building and I'm gonna
try to add two or maybe even three more
floors to that because when I did look
at it it seemed like it was just a tiny
bit higher than the rest of the
buildings in the city and that's not
what I need I needed to be a lot higher
it really needs to be that signature
tower of Silver City so that's why I'm
gonna erase that thing and I'm gonna
remove the spire which is gonna take
quite a bit of time I'm gonna build with
two more floors which is not going to
take as much time and then I'm gonna
have to rebuilt the spider because I
haven't saved anything
yay and then my other plans because I've
got plenty of plans for this problem
yeah I mean I know that last time in I
think it was my let's play that I said
it I said that I would quit this park
but that was just telling you guys that
I would quit this park because it's not
gonna happen too soon I'm still gonna
make quite a bit of episode stuff
because I do want to end this thing I do
want to finish it but then again I don't
want to just leave it hanging and just
quickly round it all up I do want to
make it nice and one of that one of the
things that I'm going to do is what I'm
currently doing adding loads of pikes to
my cities because I do want loads of
well greenery in my cities I don't
really like concrete jungles without any
nature or foliage or any of that stuff
for example when I look at Tokyo I just
I really like the city for the skyline
and the buildings that it has but dear
God there's barely any foliage in that
city somebody should give them some
trees because I would not like to live
in a city without any trees so yeah
that's what I do want to get along and
which is going to happen in the city and
hopefully it's gonna make it look a lot
better like it usually does with the
parks so I'm secretly kind of hoping for
that for the foliage to just magically
make everything look beautiful which is
hopefully gonna happen and that's what
I'm gonna try and the only buildings
that I'm really gonna build site from
the buildings that I'll have so far is
some things near the boulevard near the
water of course because you know that's
very important you do need that whatever
front going and maybe even some American
houses because of course this is America
and we do need that stuff but that's
going to happen in the next episode so
see you then